this show is brought to you by the cash
app it's the number one finance app in
the App Store you probably know cash app
is the easiest way to send money to your
friends
Benten does it right Benton you need to
use cash shop but cash app does way more
than that it also comes with the cash
car that's what you do yeah I love it
it's a free debit card that comes with
boosts which are like instant rewards
for shopping at the places you already
love you can get up to 10% off your
entire purchase at door - and even save
every time you shop at Whole Foods what
you need at Whole Foods and Target and
more right yeah if use the cash app and
your Amazon Prime membership what you
save so much and hopefully is also the
easiest way to try and grow your money
with their new investing feature I love
this
unlike investing tools that force you to
buy entire shares of stock cash app lets
you instantly invest as little or as
much as you want this way you can own a
piece of any stock with just $1
unbelievable that's democracy at its
finest brokerage services are provided
by cash up investing a subsidiary of
square and member si PC I'm also very
excited to be working with cash app to
support one of my favorite organizations
The Trevor Project when you sign up for
the cash app use the promo code Whitney
not only will you instantly receive $10
but the cash app will also donate $10 to
The Trevor Project amazing American nope
it's an amazing organization it is also
American I think it's an American
amazing the fact that I haven't started
yet is kind of a miracle
it's an organization provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services to LGBTQ youth across America
are you for that against that I'm
debating really still address download
the cash app from the App Store today
[Music]
you wake Benson you hear ya hear you up
I'm ready hey girl you up yeah you ready
for this episode 4 it's my fourth day
Ripa so I made a mistake that I'd like
to talk to you about
I made the grave mistake of trying to
buy face wash online clicking on a
charcoal face wash and now my algorithm
is very stupid I'm in that I'm in and
wellness algorithm and I need I need out
I need help
I saw because I was like trying to write
a joke about how the Wellness this
bullshit wellness industry that is
robbing women blind with these stupid
fake miracle cures here we go here we
are overcharging them for bullshit cures
for fake problems I love that we're
going back to old timey cures we have
antibiotics we have science and now
we're like let's use charcoal that's
true yeah let's you know what while
we're at it let's not use vaccines or
antibiotics like why do people hate
technology so much it just drives me
nuts but I got it so I got it his
algorithm right cuz I clicked on the
charcoal face wash and then I'm getting
marketed crystal water bottles you know
I don't you know you know I own crystal
water but I do it was sent to me in
these crystal water bottles time is up
on the crystal water bottles people
there are $100 $120 for fucking water
bottle that has a crystal in it which is
taking up space in the water bottle
which means you're getting less water
it's a water bottle that you can't put a
lot of water in the one thing you need
the hydration you're not even getting
but my Instagram likes we're gonna be on
fire crystal water bottle you can't out
wellness me Oh who decided that crystals
are medicine they're not medicine
they're very pretty
Oh
aesthetically the bomb but it okay but
maybe what crystals refer like loser
number one crystals were like people
want to see my pyrite you're like no if
I can lose they're going from me now you
have an amethyst necklace on and
everybody's wet for you like it's crazy
crystal used to be for Dora
yes I remember they're like the goth
kids in my school would have like tigers
I had necklaces and it was like weird
yeah or they're Italian like me do you
have my mom you spent me where when I
have a baby a tiger's eye bracelet for
what protects you from the evil eye
that's what Italians believe even why
Italians that's how you ward off evil
are you Italian yeah my mom is Italian I
didn't know that Wow nice to meet you
we're actual strangers wait so what
happened to the tiger eye necklace I
mean bracelet I had one in a bunch of
sizes growing up I probably one in my
house did it protect you from the evil
eye I think I'm doing pretty well yeah I
would say so you keep those spirits away
it look nice there's nothing else don't
put jewelry on your baby maybe Oh safety
hazard the teething necklaces baby's
teeth on that are made of crystal bad
okay I guess my okay look I'm gonna tell
you something right now
crystals do reduce stress in your life
because if you talk about owning
crystals less people want to hang out
with you and that will clear up your
schedule and you will have less stress
that's for sure okay having a lot of
crystals talking about owning them you
will get sick less because there will be
less germs around you because less
people will want to be around you you
won't catch anything because you know
what staying out with you I do I just be
like the reason that they work is not
the reason you think they want to see
both effect they don't they ward off
ambition I think it's because you're you
you like them and then you're around
them all the time and when you're
anything you like you're happy
well that's placebo effect placebo
effect is in effect yeah I've just had
it with these this it's a magical
crystals or a magic cure you seem like
the person who would be into this
I don't you the grounding grounding from
this point of view that's I know you
because one time you told me you had
told me once that horses are conductors
for ground that's correct so you want us
to say you know what these crystals fake
but I believe the energy travels through
my horse we get a charge from the earth
when we stand barefoot on it that's more
electromagnetic horse that is just the
crystals is different a crystal it's a
rock I mean I was reading an article I
don't know where it was I should
probably link it to this because a bunch
of people run it come at me for this oh
yeah this is make the horoscope for the
horse no people are well first of all
you put me on full-blast by Capricorn
comment there come and Woodworks let me
know I'm just saying like the crystal
therapy it's wild to me that people like
it helps you take deep breaths and helps
calm you you know you know who really
needs to take deep breaths are the coal
miners that are digging this shit up who
are getting lung cancer cuz they're
digging up your fucking crystals for you
to put on your bedside table in
Brentwood in your mansion them just down
there with like inhalers like like how
come the crystals are working for the
coal miners that cannot breathe all the
Canaries are wearing amethyst it's so
nobody sees the irony in this I just
think in general this wellness culture
is getting out of control I just it's
just voodoo witchcraft I can have your
crystal salt lamp is on the way okay
okay
the Himalayan salt lamp that does ionize
the air Joe Rogan has one and he is
facts are facts and facts are fact your
horse is a car battery this crystal lamp
is a purifier there's I just think it's
a fine line I am actually pretty new
agey in a lot of if there's science to
back it up but I think we've gone too
far I am working with people that use
new age science New Age science
I love the old sign you know that I just
woke up in my brains a little murky but
also I know people that are using
natural toothpaste and their breath
smells like a goldfish bowl and we got
to put a stop to it
natural remedies are good up to a point
but you cannot create a hostile work
environment
with your scallop breath you gotta brush
your teeth with real toothpaste Monday
Friday and chew real gum people are out
there too and natural gum natural gum
the first ingredient is sugar sugar
shouldn't be in your gum I if you are
out a work place environment with human
beings your gum better give you a chill
you know when you get that minty ass
menthol gum and your nipples get hard
from it that's the kind of gum you need
be chewing at work
I want your butthole to go up in your
body then all your teeth break that one
that one yeah it should feel like bleach
it should it should hurt it should be
physically painful the gum you're
chewing at work yeah goldfish Bell is
really triggering for me that was like
too accurate
that's gross that's exactly what it's
meant someone has that black cold water
you're like something died in your
stomach and then I have to like it's
like secondhand smoke like your breath
is your responsibility you cannot spread
bad breath in the office because then
I'm an asshole if I say something true
there's an epidemic of halitosis in this
country and crystals are not gonna fix
it we'll see I heard if you just like to
swish some crystals around you but
that's not what's your self-care stuff
makeup Penna do you pray every day yeah
how many times a day twice once here
once wet once what once on the way here
once in the way back you pray in your
car well yeah cuz there's a cross I
always see inside just let us use that
time how long oh um
sometimes they're really quick sometimes
they're long sometimes I'm like I have a
lot to say things for in some time just
like I need a little bit of help and a
little bit of strength give me through
this and then have you ever prayed about
me yes really before I told you I
couldn't be your assistant I prayed for
a good week instead but solid I was like
I might I might be ruining my life I'm
so sorry if you got me here and I'm
messing it up oh but I have to tell her
this get me straight yeah they weren't
that well blessing highly favored you
are sure no one knows what that means
you have to explain it listen Pete
Benton you don't know what that means
Benton thinks a podcast is a private
conversation with me with all of our
inside jokes and not even do with a joke
you have to explain them to strangers
lesson highly favored her blessing on
your favor you can hardly get it out of
your mouth no nobody's black in here
black women would know what I'm talking
about okay
blessed in highly favored this one you
blessed me you just say it with
absolutely no contact whatsoever
but did you want to know more no we're
gone on too long
I know but have you heard that shut up
you know what I need to I need to pray
my way out of this because Nicole Byers
here
I know love her yeah Nicole Byer if she
don't know what it means nailed it yes
she will I don't like the sound of my
own voice you have an incredible but
that's what the people say yeah and the
people don't lie have you notice that
people on Instagram don't lie they don't
give compliments and really really do I
don't really mean lady the other day
just really leaned into me
she called my hands chido dusted black
roaches it was kind of funny but I was
also like you could use this like for
good like you're pretty creative you
gonna call me fat I've made so much
money being fat so what do you have we
started I don't know have we yeah I
think so
that's how natural this is I love it I
though have done the auto block have you
ever done that on instrum you can auto
block comments no oh wait how do you do
that you can block certain key words
word in it it's automatically blocked so
I blocked words like whore okay busted
busted whore did you fuck Joe Rogan you
learn a lot about yourself when you
start picking the mind that you oughta
block I just it I've never in my life
wanted to say something nasty to someone
on social media I feel like it should be
illegal to comment anything other than
you look wonderful
or a variation of that I was talking to
my therapist which unfortunately happens
a lot and I Oh fortunately it is
medicine mm-hmm and I was talking to her
because there were some comments that
were eating at me mm-hmm
because a couple people I guess banded
together and all started making the same
comment after my last special came out
and and I told her about it and I was
like and this guy commented this then
this about my face and said I had
plastic surgery and then called me a
whore and did it and she just goes Wow
sounds like they're in a lot of pain
mm-hmm and I was like how dare you
sympathize with
monsters what you'd think like well yeah
how much pain must yeah yeah like you're
very upset in order to say awful things
like that this dude I read my Dan's
because I read nasty come-ons on my
podcast from DMS so this person was like
you're not funny and I hate you and I
just wrote back I was like I hope that
made you feel better and I hope the rest
of your day went well he commented back
you know what I was having a really
terrible day I hope you keep making
people laugh but not me and see well
there's also this new thing that I guess
social media has illuminated like I
don't need to be for everyone know the
idea that like we need to be everybody's
cup of tea it's just wild insane it's a
very strange way to think I keep getting
asked about like canceled culture and
stuff like that in interviews and I was
like yeah I don't like canceled culture
you don't have to like someone's full
special know you can like 90% of it yeah
and not cancel the whole thing yeah you
can just go 90% of it was for me 10% was
not so uh I respect the work you put in
to put out an hour of original material
nobody's really talking about that I
mean social media is such an addiction
it does give us dopamine our dopamine
receptors make dopamine or you get
adrenaline which turns into dopamine I
do have you ever tried to turn your
phone on to grayscale I have it's
upsetting does it last very long no
because the dopamine doesn't happen
that's right so for those of you who
don't know what she's talking about this
is a brilliant trick that makes you a
little less addicted to your phone yes
you because part of what's so addicted
and and sexy about it other than colors
if you put it in grayscale which i think
is maybe applications it's really hard
to I know they do because they don't
want you believe your phone's down and
then everything's in black and white so
it just becomes less yeah it's like
reading a newspaper and yeah and nearly
yeah I know it's funny babies like
bright colors yes so we just never
evolved past that Oh baby but negativity
especially self-righteous didn't
Ignatian is a drug and we're all high
yes I think so
especially people on the left they like
really want to get offended about
everything on this high horse and be
very offended and I'm like okay I've
never seen I mean I don't know if this
is new I can't say but it's like people
want to be victims yeah they want to get
hurt yeah it's like like I remember like
five years ago noticing that people
would brag about being sick you'd be
like oh my god I'm so sick like oh my
god I couldn't sleep last night they
brag about how little sorry yeah yes and
I was like oh it's almost like a
Munchausen thing we're people like I'm
discriminated against it's like uh-huh
are you awake millionaire I'm so sorry
I'm confusing trying to figure out how
your victim
[Music]
do you know Mateo Lane love him someone
I love him just a fan so dearly he's a
dear friend of mine and his body is
about time women objecting to do it oh
all the time whenever he's at my house I
might take off for sure yeah that's true
equality that men fight also and he does
it loving but he posted a picture and
wrote Ola and then someone was like oh
another white dude appropriating culture
and he was like I'm Mexican
he's part Mexican and I was like this is
so wild that somebody just got offended
that he said hola even if he wasn't part
Mexican oh it just means a lot and it
differently it's not appropriate it's so
nuts so then I comment I was like you
got throw him in jail I got in trouble
because I said it's some like panel
someone was a basket case mm-hmm people
came for me is that like a slur now it
is it is in World War one or two if
soldiers had lost all their limbs and
could've been on a basketball no I'm the
one offending World War two soldiers
Nazis earth would you have known that
didn't know look I'm happy to
course-correct
last thing I want to do is upset
somebody and my last special I'd end up
cutting stuff out cuz I said Native
American and some was like I think you
have to say indigenous people and I was
like you know
yeah I don't I don't know to get this
wrong yeah they've had it bad enough yet
last thing I need to do is make a joke
like I just and I wanted to hold up in
ten years yes so I'm happy to make
concessions but y'all like giving in to
take a mile
dang it someone could have just pulled
you aside on me like do you know the
origin of basket case yeah could have
been like now and then I could have told
you you've been like now I know and now
now pick and choose when I said also I
think I was calling myself about like
I'm insulting myself but then also don't
colloquialisms maybe derive from
something and then evolve into something
else I think we all just go addicted to
the attention we are getting from like
publicly shaming people I get
embarrassing people it's really I come
from I come from the codependent culture
of if someone has food in their teeth
don't say something like you never let
you never embarrass somebody publicly oh
so the fact that everyone wants to just
publicly shame people like to do that
loudly but I'll just be a nice friend
and be like yeah I like pull people
aside now I used to get a pit in my
stomach about the idea of telling
someone like wow oh good I used to get
like because I don't wanna embarrass
somebody that's a nightmare mmm the
other day I used a lady's own finger to
get lipstick off her teeth because it
was too much for her to like just lick
off so that's a very basket case as
thing yeah I'm a real basket case so I
have this thing in my head that were
really close friends I like you a lot
but we don't hang out very often were
literal strangers but I've been a fan
for a long time and I listen your
podcast and I think we're very close but
I want to do this quiz with you those
can help me sort of understand a little
bit more about you know I'll tell you
what it means at the end I'm kind of
doing it with all the guests you need to
tell me your favorite animal my favorite
animal but not like your dog or a dog
you have the animal you admire your
favorite animal I think koala might be
my favorite because they're really cute
and cuddly but they'll like claw your
eyes out love it I think yeah I didn't
know that about koalas yeah they're
dangerous okay like they have a little
claws I think those claws
used to kill people am I making this up
does anyone know am i right I'm sure
they'll let you know you've appropriated
I'll sent three things to describe a
koala cute cuddly
close your eyes out dangerous mhmmm
anything else about them
small small I like that they're small
they're small yeah but cute and cuddly
yeah okay favorite article of clothing
my favorite article of clothing it was
this tobacco colored cardigan but I lost
it I've seen that I wear it a lot where
do you lose it I have no idea this is
heartbreaking
yeah it's having an article I'm loving
sometimes I look at photos and I'll see
like a sweatshirt I wore for five years
and I don't know I don't know what we
tour so it's incidental to I think it is
offered in tears yes yeah three words to
describe your tobacco colored cardigan
comfy hmm a little tight long enough to
cover my butt so like what's another
word to describe that like in one word
like not protective tasty I mean like
it's a tasteful oh I like it and then
your favorite body of water it can be a
swimming pool it can be a specific lake
I picked a new river in West Virginia
cuz I spent and then they're growing up
and I love it I really like Barton
Springs where's that that's in Austin
Texas but I also really just like the
ocean okay I love the ocean and what are
three things to describe the oceans of
why you like um scary Oh vast huh
beautiful yeah okay so this is a this is
a test that Sigmund Freud came up with
that gives you an insight kind of into
your subconscious that kind of tells you
about sort of who you are I have a
friend who went to go interview at a
rehab and they gave her this test like
they give people these tests at a lot of
like employment organization because you
pretend in a job interview
lately get to the heart of life to get
hired yeah and so your favorite animal
is qualit this is how you view yourself
cute and cuddly I think that's pretty
accurate yeah I think that's pretty
accurate well your favorite article of
clothing is how other people view you
okay
comfy a little bit tight I'm assuming
that's very fuzzy it's about my birthday
and tasteful okay and usually there's a
big discrepancy between the way you
perceive yourself and the way other
people perceive you you have a little
one cute cuddly
comfy it seems you're very sane you see
yourself the same way other people see
you except for the eyes cloud I've been
to a lot of therapy we're gonna talk
about that so much there I have
questions
especially because ocean is the favorite
body water is the way you view sex for
you it's beautiful vest and scary I'm
broken yeah I mean no major red flags
though like the friend of mine that when
she do the interview and the rehab she's
that her favorite animal was a cougar
because they pulled their prey up into a
tree so no one else can steal it but
also at a rehab that means she wants to
keep people safe yeah that's a good
point I think they missed the mark they
saw it as a red flag when did you start
going to therapy um the first time I
went to therapy was family therapy
because I was acting out and they were
like you want attention right which is
not the way you give someone attention
like that was just shaming now yeah yeah
and then I went to therapy after my mom
died and I went to this there I was 16
she had bright bright blonde hair red
lipstick and then too many books on her
bookshelf and I was convinced that they
were all fake I can't speak to her yeah
then my next step is when I was in
College she was all the way in Brooklyn
and she tried to hypnotize me and I was
still in this place where I was polite
and like didn't tell people what was up
so she did not hypnotize me and I told
her she did I you I don't think people
under their pen yeah I used to do it all
the time the therapist I'm with now is
the only one that called me out of my
shit like life shouldn't be this hard
yeah I need to figure out what's going
on and then my friend Marcy was like I
have a therapist for you and she she's
the one who family my therapist and I
met with her and I was like I like her I
feel like I can trust her and I felt
comfortable just telling her things yeah
so that and that's so important I think
a lot of people in this white 12-step
programs work - is it as soon as you
tell someone something and they don't go
you're a monster
yeah this is shame yes or as soon as
someone relates to what you're saying
and when we say our fears out loud the
fear all of a sudden dissipates because
your frontal lobe engages so it's like
it's not just about what they're doing
it's just being able to talk to someone
who's not gonna judge you or hold you
you know captive for mobile units you're
telling yeah and then after an hour she
goes bye-bye yeah I did about me for
that hour you're not a miser you're not
disgusting everybody does it this is
totally normal you're not a weirdo yeah
the thing I liked the most was in our
first session she was like so why do you
want to be in therapy and I was like to
change into a better person she was like
well why would you want to change who
you are and I was like I'm broken she's
like more you broke it or do you just
have issues that you need to figure out
how to work with or or make them work
for you and I was like oh okay yeah
essentially was like you know we're all
clay and you mold into what you wanted
and sometimes we over pathologized
especially a perfectionist you know or
whatever inner bully comes up when I
went into 12-step programs and
therapists for the first time I wanted
to be the best at it I wanted to win I
wanted to be there I wanted to be her
best client and her most fucked up her
favorite I want to be the most
unrecovered person in 12-step programs
and then I like a competitive about it
and I was like I'm totally over
pathologizing win though like that's not
that big of it you still go to 12 so I
do yeah yeah my therapist
she was like twelve-step in al-anon is
good even if you don't have an erection
she was like you might figure out some
other sort of addiction that's right and
I did try to go to a a meeting once and
it was just a little too much it's a lot
it was a little much for me I might go
back one day but it was just it was a
little a little too much I want to
circle back to that I first want to say
the reason I decided to stay with my
therapist is I was talking about an ex
mmm-hmm and was just like you know for
severing about it constantly obsessing
and and she finally went we're done oh
no more because you're just reinventing
the trauma like your narrative making it
bigger than it is like like now you have
to not talk about it for 28 days hmm so
there is a happy medium between talking
about things and sharing and then over
sharing and obsessing so she was like
you're an obsession so now I'm gonna
need you to not talk about this to
anyone for twenty miracle because I also
needed someone who didn't like liberate
me from yeah just feel like you don't
have to because the more you over share
with your friends then they're gonna
keep asking you about it then you have
to keep talking about it then you're
still in your so her thing is all about
restraint of pen and tongue don't share
this with all your friends you don't
have to tell everybody everything I'm
learning that it's a hard one cuz it's
like why I like to talk about my life on
stage so why wouldn't I tell me about us
but then lately I've been like well why
don't you just keep some things to
yourself
mm-hmm it's a way of self-care yes I
remember I was in everywhere whether
this person came up to me I was like
how's your knee and I was like mm-hmm oh
god I told someone about that on the
pocket you know it's just the what we
put out there in the world we that have
to live with forever and then people
like that and you're like white lady you
do I have any values you have any
concept of keeping you know we have to
protect our energy and we have to
protect our future selves you know I you
know talked a lot about like addiction
love addiction and anorexia in the book
I wrote and I don't regret doing it but
I do sometimes with the amount of people
that come up to me want to talk about it
sometimes I'm yeah
oh no I've moved on yes and they're like
but I just but I just found it I want to
talk to you about it no but I think well
that's why I have the book
if you read the book in your house and
you leave it in your house when you're
healed but then part of a 12-step
program is being of service and going on
there's still people who are sick and
suffering and I wish there was a book
out there of someone that have talked
about this and I would go talk to her in
an airport and this is the only person
that sees me so it comes with a
responsibility but there is a little bit
of a pressure
oh absolutely like a lot of people I
posted on social media like any
questions for Nicole and a lot of people
wanted me to ask you about like how to
love yourself and how you're comfortable
in your body and I was like I feel like
she hears this question constantly oh
and I don't even want to ask her you
can't visit my passive-aggressive way of
asking no no you can but it must be
exhausting it is exhausting because it's
also insulting to to see it like a fat
black woman be like how on earth does
she look in the mirror and be okay it's
like well if I wasn't then I would be so
miserable so why not look in the mirror
and choose to like what you see back
yeah if you don't like it you could
change it like people are like you're so
body-positive I'm like not really I'm
just truly like do what makes you happy
if you want big lips go get big lips
yeah if you want to change something on
your face change it for it but like if
you don't have the means and you don't
want to like you don't have to you can
just choose to like what you see yeah
and then I used to look at myself naked
an old acting teacher was like look at
yourself naked and that's the type that
that person gave me to do you like what
you see daddy
no he's doodle load because he was like
trying to get you comfortable with
typing typing yeah and he was like if
you don't like what you see change it so
you're a different type he's like when
you first start out you will be typecast
yeah if you don't play these parts
change what you look like and I was like
that's pretty solid advice yeah I don't
see like shitty advice it's the same way
yeah but I yeah I think you love what
you have or you change what you have and
then you learn to love that I do though
feel like there's a little bit of there
was this moment a couple years ago where
everyone was like allowed to be
vulnerable and all that then it was like
super interesting to like talk about
your flaws and yeah I don't like this
about myself like I'm insecure and I
have
this and and then I think in the last
year now there's like a bullying about
like you're not allowed to self
technically you're like yeah I just I
thought we were admitting our flaws I
thought we were allowed to say we're
insecure it's like well that's your
setting about example like
self-identification is now over hey it's
so confusing as to what you can and
can't do like I spent maybe like a good
six months eight months trying to figure
how to tell fat jokes because I would
get on stage and be like I'm fat and
everyone go oh come on you get why to me
I heard the stage creak when I stepped
like I'm a bigger lady and it's okay I'm
fine with it
I didn't leave my house to go I'm fat
and have everyone go no you're not and I
go great let me go home I just let me
tell the jokes and it took so long and
then I figured out I have to tell the
jokes in a way as to how the audience
views me interesting yeah it was just
like it was a lot of like mental
Olympics to get there yeah it's it's
just kind of like a wild time although
in terms of the self deprecation thing
like I get the point of like we
shouldn't degrade ourselves
unnecessarily for a laugh but also we're
allowed to I don't need to feel sorry
for me yes if I see myself a certain way
and you also don't get to decide how I
see myself like correct there's a little
bit of this moment in like body
positivity where there's and you know
I'm pretty open about like having eating
disorder having had eating disorders now
I have what we call disordered eating
because we're never totally out of the
woods we don't dis order tea you don't
say we're cured like you never say I'm
cured for my eating disorder because a
lot of eating disorders come from sexual
abuse and they come it's relate an
addiction to control stuff like that so
sometimes it's not even really about
food it comes it goes it's kind of like
whack-a-mole with your addictions you
know you fix this thing this comes up
and fix this thing this comes up it kind
of just moves around so it really
depends on where I am in terms of my
like over committing or toxic
friendships kind of like stuff like that
it'll sort of come and go but they
discourage saying like I'm you're cute
it sort of disordered you know which is
sort of like you know for me it was
really more just about like I just
thought about it too much
there was the obsession of what did I
eat him what am I gonna eat and uh and I
was just a very dysmorphic perception of
my body but a lot of people there's this
aiming of Hollywood for the standard of
beauty which I'm I'll blame it all day
long but a lot of people get their body
stuff when they're kids
oh yeah they've read vogue I fully agree
with you my mother was on a diet I think
since the day I was born
yep she was always like on Weight
Watchers I went to Weight Watchers
meetings with a little kid up my
grandparents are Island people and
Island people for whatever reason are
obsessed with weight they are truly it
is their bread and butter no pun
intended but they're just like why are
you so big why are you so small like I
was always too big my sister was always
too small nobody was ever okay so I that
happened before I ever before people had
the tools to know that's gonna leave a
mark I try to forgive that generation I
feel like we're the first generation
with even a modicum of understanding of
hate when you say things your kid hears
it yes you can't say rez shit like that
also kids are smarter than we all think
I always say kids are stupid but it's a
joke people get so angry when I'm like I
hate them like it's kind of a joke but
like also like badly behaved children I
dunno when it's right and when you're in
play as much as we are ya understand
what we have they're bad but I handed
out candy at Halloween and they told
this little girl I said well don't you
look fun and smart and she went oh thank
you and then as she was leaving she went
that's my favorite house and I was like
oh cuz nobody ever tells little girls
are smart and they like it um oh boy I'm
gonna mispronounce her name but she
hosts top chef Pat Benton vented on pat
pat ha ha Padma I'm not and I cannot
pronounce her last name and I feel very
terribly I met her daughter at the Emmys
and I told her she looked fun and smart
and she went more people should tell
little girls that I was like who you are
a little girl yeah and this is very
astute of you I get my brother by I've
nieces that are really gorgeous and I
just I don't I am around them and I'm
just like don't say anything don't do
anything don't look at your phone and
then when I'm eating around them I'm
like eat the whole plate like I guess
I'm so terrified of speeding them up
hard but what you can do which I learned
when I was around
my nieces and nephews is you can say
that you've made a mistake mm-hm or you
can say you know that helped me a lot
like when I'd get insecure I would say
something me and my brother would joke
around and we're too caustic with each
other I would go like oh I don't really
mean that
sometimes I'm insecure and I make jokes
and it's coming from a place of fear
yeah and then they're like okay like
just giving them more credit you're not
lying
understand shit all we do is lie to them
yeah all we do is pretend like I
remember watching my parents pretend to
like each other I knew something I knew
it I was like there this doesn't feel
real real bad acting a bad long-form
improv show but I would not say I'm good
because we have like this gut reptilian
instinct and then what kids end up doing
is they start doubting themselves they
start going I must be crazy
mm-hmm I must be stupid that I don't
understand what's going on I'm the weird
one but they are stupid that you do you
know my kids really just never have no I
used to want kids I just want eight
children
oh um specific number I know well eights
my favorite numbers I was like my bacon
and I picked out a name for one of my
children it was starlit Jade Rose Marie
what an ugly name star starlet Jade Rose
Marie it's a beautiful new you I also
want to name my first kid Rocky so I'm
not a I like rocky right like rocky I
like boys names for girls I like I like
that yeah for me store know what store
me it's kind of a you can't why not
store meters come on it's a after a
Jenner and so why did you decide you
didn't want kids
oh I was a nanny for about two and a
half years maybe three years so even
getting paid to be around yeah I was
like oh no yeah cuz I would take a nap
when they went now and then sometimes I
was like pretty good at like waking up
before them but sometimes the little boy
would wake up before me and I'd wake up
to the only Shibani huggers
that's all he ate okay I do fight with
him to eat like a hot dog okay Jen
Bunney
he loved blueberry he loved raspberry
vanilla I think is so good
I once bought one of those giant tubs
cuz I was like I'll never get through
this but you better believe I did taste
like gummy spit to me yes it just
reminds me of what could be I had this
wild thing where I think I always just
assumed I was gonna have kids and I'm
that's what I'm biologically designed
just want and socially constructed shit
all you need to do or else I shouldn't
exist in my monster or a sociopath and
then I was like okay and then I finally
was like wait I don't think I want to
have them I think I would adopt like I
rescue dogs and I feel like having your
own kid at this point it's kind of like
buying from a breeder like wouldn't I
rescue a kid my dad died a couple years
ago and I had this biological urge that
was like I need to make a copy of him Oh
interest and then all of a sudden I
started thinking about kids again when
my dad died I was like close up shop
stop up that uterus done I don't want
them because you were think on some
level afraid of like more pain coming
your way yeah cuz if I have a kid I'm
gonna die that's right and then that kid
will be so sad that their mother died my
parents death changes you on such a
fundamental level yes and it's the only
thing we know that's gonna happen for
sure in our lifetimes but the only thing
I was completely unprepared well nobody
prepares you for it no one just goes one
day it's going to happen and then you
have to do so you have to be sad and
then you have to settle their estate and
then warns you about paperwork no just
it's so much fucking paperwork and it's
expensive when somebody dies bets have a
shit and my dad didn't do anything when
my mom died so then they were all like
well next to kin is his wife I'm like
she did too they're like what yeah
here's our death certificate yes if you
don't have enough now I need you to sign
these papers and decide and then that's
so excretion is so expensive to burn my
body is like oh that would be the
cheapest yeah heard of the whole thing
but you have to buy a casket to then
burn somebody or somebody in another
thing people don't tell you about when
death happens is it's fucking gross yeah
it's gross and there's a button it's the
person that you love more than anything
and there might as well have vultures be
picking at them and you're like this is
so wrong
it's I went into an existential crisis
it's bad nothing matters I turn it into
a total denial is yeah but one upside to
it and this is how I'm gonna circle back
to the 12-step program think a lot of
the things that I went into a strip
we're gonna talk about that about
stripping clearly another thing a lot of
the reason that I went into a 12-step
program mm-hmm kind of magically clicked
into place when my dad passed maybe it's
because I was so sad and grief just
makes you a lot of you're codependent
shit goes away because you don't have
the time or energy to take care of it
yeah else's feeling so I went into a
12-step program because I you know
defined myself through other people I
did enough through my productivity I had
to basically couldn't tolerate the
discomfort of others people's needs
before my own was it a bunch of
relationships with people I had to
rescue or save was always in a dramatic
situation but always saying I don't like
drama but like people who say they don't
like that's drama live and I always
would victimize myself give too much to
people so that then they could never
possibly reciprocate in a way that held
equal so that I would recreate my
childhood circumstance of being a victim
that the left couldn't say no to people
was over committed I was doing stuff for
free left and right every charity event
in Oxnard I was there I'm at the ice
house I'm hosting every show I do
perform a lot for the amount of other
work that you do it's kind of Inc every
time I see you like at The Improv I'm
like oh she's doing this why can't she
just crazy failure I mean yeah
[Music]
italic I really love this brand I'm not
joking this is makes me so happy
italic cuts out brands and retailers to
sell unbranded luxury goods and insane
prices there's lots of stuff for both
men and women from luxury handbags
wallets cashmere sweaters bedding bath
towels cookware even water bottles from
the best possible manufacturers in each
category I hate when people have giant
logos on their shoes
I why are you advertising for this
company you paid for the shirt and now
you work for them yeah unless you didn't
pay for this shirt well that's a whole
lot of widgets you don't deserve it I
just it makes me nuts like why do I work
for you why does it have to say your
company across my chest not for me it
makes me and say neither of us are
branding it I don't want to be a walking
billboard but this company you can get
great gifts for your loved ones this
year without breaking the bank don't
show up again with a pair of socks how
dare you treat the special person in
your life or your BFF is something
beautiful they deserve it be smart don't
pay $1,000 for a logo don't be a tool
don't be a sheep bowl-shaped I'm not
gonna stop my producers try to get me to
stop doing this ad but I actually feel
very passionate about that you need to
save your money for more important
things like like did you know fashion is
the second largest pollutant in the
world cuz I'm shocked by that oh wow
well why don't you start your own
podcast and talk about that you can get
sheets from the same manufacturer a st.
Regis and the Four Seasons leather bags
by the same manufacturer as Celine and
Prada and even a candle from the same
supplier as la la bow for less than the
price of a textbook sign you up
well you Google get on this for me no
joke for the first time ever italic is
offering a credit to my listeners use
the code Whitney for a twenty dollar
credit that can go toward any order over
$100 on any italic products including
bags from the same manufacturer as proud
of betting from the same manufacturer
st. Regis or even sneakers from the same
manufacturers as Church don't be silly
it's all unbranded it's all ridiculously
priced don't play yourself all right you
guys Benton is very excited for this one
I can't wait I know
calm down away luggage I already have it
we do we all we have
I have all the luggage they tried to
send me some and I was like I already
got it no thanks
away creates thoughtful products built
for the way modern travelers see the
world they started with the perfect
suitcase and now they offer a range of
essentials all which will make your
travels more seamless whoever said it's
about the journey has never traveled
during the holidays it's the most
stressful craziest time to be on the
road but a waste products are designed
to work and fit together making travel
smoother for the holidays and beyond you
know that I use the backpack me too we
have matching backpack well with
different colors I like the because you
could put your computer in the back
mm-hmm and the most genius part about it
I don't even think this is in the copy I
have but you can charge your freaking
phone in it and then the there's a
charger here yeah you can charge your
phone with your suitcase like what mad
genius it truly is the Piranha vadas it
really is no this is the most genuine
I've ever seen you I love it we bond
over all the time I have both the
backpack that the travel bag you have
all the luggage tell you my favorite
part about it actually is that they come
in colors that aren't black yes whenever
you go get your luggage it's always like
30 black suitcases and mine is like
bright yellow mine's bright red again
I'm run away right away ha I like them I
don't even need to read this copy
special offer oh lucky you guys for $20
off any suitcase our bag visit away
travel calm slash quit now and use promo
code quit now during checkout that's $20
off any suitcase or bag visit away
travel calm backslash quit now and use
promo code Whitney during checkout I
know I have to say it once because my
producer is going to say people don't
know how to spell witness and if you
guys don't know how to spell my name I
have bigger problems the world wants you
to fail kind of like people not like the
industry the industry want you to
succeed right because everybody wants to
be the person who found that / that's
right
and like broke that person yet like
people want to see you fall they want to
build you out of it
to watch you fucking love it just it's
so crazy I remember when I was doing a
couple TV shows literally - the day that
they got picked up I do not hear from
any of my friends and as soon as one guy
cancelled everyone's like what's up what
a hang-its just was like I was almost
relieved when I publicly failed because
I was like oh I get to have friends
again mm-hmm like people are gonna like
me again cuz but I get it I understand
is so
shitty it is but I also understand that
other people's perceived success can be
triggering it makes you hold up a mirror
to your own insecurities and not
everyone's out there doing the kind of
work you're doing I guess yes you know
yeah I mean I guess it did take me a
minute to be excited for other people's
successes mm-hmm because through therapy
I learned if I didn't get it it wasn't
for me that's right if a somebody else
books it they weren't looking for me and
then two minutes fine and it's also like
I can now basically define my success or
failure based on how much grace I was
able to have letting go something that
wasn't meant for me yes and that's it
you know and I used to take it as an
opportunity to like hurt myself you know
and feel bad and I was sort of like what
a nurse is yeah we all do yeah I mean
auditioning and acting is a gambling
addiction truly that's it and also if
you book one out of every hundred job
doing so well wild success you're doing
so good I don't know anything about
sports but in baseball the best pitchers
that make like forty million dollars a
year and have like an 11 percent hitting
percentage batting person throwing
percentage I don't know one thing about
grief because I have talked about a
little bit that when it happened I was
thankfully a lot of things clicked into
place
mm-hmm and June Rafer like she called me
and she was like I can't help you
through this the type of pain you're
about to go through it's unimaginable
you know
grief is mercurial don't judge yourself
grieving but you're gonna lose some
friends some friends are gonna become
strangers and then the McWane cesare
gonna become friends Oh through the
grieving process because I realize like
some people did go away when I was no
longer performing or funny or like the
life of the party because I was sad all
yeah I'm there are a lot of people are
like Oh Whitney sad this is me this is
not what I signed up for that's I sent
up for the insecure girl who's always
trying to make everyone laugh I was
listening to your podcast the other day
and you guys were talking about a date
that you went on with someone who was in
an open relationship yeah it's always
this isn't sound so rude
it's always the ugliest people in an
open relationship
like how come you think you can get more
yeah you have one I guess I'm in the
same room with you so so what di I think
I'm too insecure to be in an open
relationship I'm not sure the point it
seems like a like addiction to you it
seems like a lot of work yeah and oh one
person always seems really into it and
one person seems like they have you're
balding and have eye bags and if it's
they're not as into it it's always one
person who's like let's do it another
person goes well if that's what you want
I have to do this and they look sad in
the eyes yes but they're doing it
because they had I used to think I could
do an open relationship because I was
like when I'm on the road do whatever
but then I was like no no I think I'd
like to be on the road and call that
person and have them want to miss me and
want to want me to come home I'm just
unclear the rules like I don't know I'm
the person at game night that's like
there are rules the rules an open
relationship I just yeah it's like a
spreadsheet of rules yes and I'm
Dyslexic ie it's not for me I read a
Huffington Post
oh excuse me a throuple if you will but
it was too queer people living together
with kids and then they introduced a
third a girlfriend but she's only the
girlfriend of one of the people but then
the other one is best friends with that
person and then she also helps raise the
kids but she doesn't live there she only
sleeps there sometimes and I was like
Tao seems like so much work it seems
like a lot of work and I maybe check
back with me in 10 years yeah Wendy I'm
like wait my Nana is kind of cute and
helping out like I get you should fuck
because I'm hired yeah because I'm gone
so much I mean I've a sex robot of
myself and I was like can you have sex
with this well I'm oh I get it that's
what this open relationship do you see
that more and more I've been dating you
or was it always just more hidden before
not hidden because there's always people
being like we're a couple looking for
our a in a car
[Music]
which is like so depressing just like
looking for our third or magical person
who will not get attached to us but
suckas oh and it's usually a very ugly
couple and you're like I wouldn't fuck
either of you both of you like tutus
doesn't equal a ten yes like what is
this correct that's a lot of tinder I
see a lot of tinder people or open
relation yeah tinder is honestly the
manifestation of depression like it is
so sad to open up tinder and start
swiping I went on there recently because
I was like doing some whatever thing and
I mean there was a guy in a black rubber
suit with like a thing at like an auto
speed deviation like that straight up
David Carradine Asian like it's like
damn like it's a yeah I'll let it all
hang out good for you a man messaged me
recently he was in a bunny costume and
he said I want to hop on your face and I
was like I don't know what that means do
you want to stomp on my face or do you
want to sit on my face are you trying to
be cute because you're a bunny what's
happened I don't like guys and this is
maybe very old school of me I don't like
guys that wear cop I don't like guys
that dress up as babies for Halloween I
don't like any of that infantilizing
shit I like a man in jeans huh with
calluses hell yeah like neck hair yeah
straight up I'm pretty open to any old
person because when I see someone in a
costume or something like Moloch and
pictures them putting it on so if a
guy's stepping into a cop buddy I'm
picturing him being like yeah I'm now
I'm not a sexually attractive yeah I
mean he wasn't attractive to begin with
and then the bunny costume made him look
insane I want to do this thing with you
because so in this area if so much good
insight this is made these this is so
professional I can't even handle this
this is a real treat cameras set up tons
of bottles of liquids a candle and cards
I love real show nine years late to the
podcast game I mean of Hatter's
good money there's good money in
podcasting I had no I'm clearly yeah
this candle $50 cancel we're just
burning it yeah good it for free that
one I bought oh no that one I did why I
do like buying things that are expensive
sometimes just for the shame head I'm
gonna feel bad well here's the thing if
you make a ton of money you can buy a
couple of expensive things I sort of
have the it's like a it's a shame cycle
where I'll buy something that's a little
bit too expensive and the elements on it
because I'm like it's I'm gonna lose it
all it's all gonna go away it could go
away in any second anytime I get a job
that pays me a decent amount of money I
take 10% of that after so like I cut it
in half to pay my agent my lawyer
everybody I and then I take 10% of that
half and then I buy something with it
I love that I try to because my dad he
used to be like Nicole once money is
gone it just gone so I hear that all the
time in my head do you think you have a
healthy relationship with money no I'm
bad at watching it yeah but like I know
that I can't possibly spend more than I
make right
I and I talked about this on another
episode when I first started making
money I was like I'm rich and then the
tax man came and I couldn't afford my
taxes yeah so I I now have a bank
account that's separate and I take 30%
of it I never see it that's smart cuz I
never have it so I don't want to see it
and then it feels like I'm getting
robbed at the end of the I just cut it
in half and then in my brain I keep a
running tally of how much I've made that
year just loose in my head I look at my
bank and I'm like that's not real what
of the things that you buy brings you
joy what works I really love my house oh
that's a huge one and I'm currently
decorating it
that to me is the most the best use of
money yeah really love it I left it
unfurnished for a year cuz I bought it
and was like what if I never work again
yep I have that every night it was a
little insane but then it's like oh you
can sell it yeah if you need to you can
just repeal it I don't want to because I
love it and then bags baggy we like bad
yeah but there's something about bags
they hold your stuff they you know
they keep you safe they keep you
organized like that's a good investment
I feel like yeah so I want to do this
thing that my therapist had me do when
cuz dating yes it's hard it's the
hardest thing I think in America but one
of the hardest things for me is when you
get neurologically wrapped up in
somebody you meet someone you're
attracted to them dopamine oxytocin
epinephrine serotonin who's happy Ephram
Padma phenylethylamine there's all these
neuro chemicals I learned cuz I freaking
had to learn about neurology when my
parents had strokes and addiction
because I have so much addiction in my
family and I started realizing like you
make a really bad choices when your
brain gets flushed with all these
chemicals you call it the internal drug
cabinet and you don't think straight and
then you have given two years of your
life to a psychopath I want to know this
is something that my therapist really
made me sit down and write out because I
was getting in really bad relationships
because out of either fear or
desperation or because the neuro
chemicals lust passion whatever I want
to make a list of your musts in a person
you're dating okay would be nice and
then red flags okay okay
and then I have mine the actual list
that I first wrote it happens to me my
boat this embarrassing I promise I'm not
promoting my book right now I just yes
you are this is the oh that's I know I'm
not gonna show it I'm not even gonna
show the cover this is not loading it
but you know we all know you know have a
book you can promote know it's here and
you can't even see it cuz I put this in
my book because it helped me so much to
just put down what the bottom lines are
I'm critical language you're using
12-step programs of things that must
happen in a relationship okay not
budging on this like woody what is one
of your like trustworthy oh yeah that's
a must
that's good petrest worthy not
negotiable no matter how hot they are no
matter how sexy are
how much dopamine you're releasing
trustworthy if someone lies it's a no
consistent I wrote that down for some
reason I think that because I'm touring
and how inconsistent our lives are I
wanted some someone who had like a
consistent thing going yeah let's see I
wrote not a comedian I mean
yeah not a comedian but then also I'm
okay with a comedian I know no I've
never dated a comedian ever I know weird
yeah they're always like instantly like
brothers to me
yes something just not cool about it to
me yeah I don't really find a dude who
needs to be funny sexy yeah it sounds
awful no it is what it is you don't have
to judge yourself yeah I'm like I guess
I don't find me sexy
no no it's also a reptilian thing like I
once was madly in love with a guy I hate
this about myself human nature is sexist
I'm sorry biology is sexist and cruel
and he tripped and fell in front of me
uh-huh it was over I hate myself I beat
myself up for it all the time don't
biology shallow and but also it might
not have been biology it might have been
like you just were not into him and that
was the thing that you were like oh I'll
blame it on this yep that sort of broke
the spell you're like oh no no thank you
oh thank you for making me feel better
about that I've been carrying that guilt
for you anytime you just arbitrarily
don't like somebody for something stupid
they have done its you didn't like them
in the first place and you were just
trying to figure out pinpointing like oh
this this is this is why I don't like
that is huge because I think that women
we a bully ourselves into staying in
relationships and going well you're just
shallow and like you're so ungrateful oh
you just don't like that person and just
call and that's okay nicest thing to do
for them yes get out of there and to
pretend and lie to someone I like for
people to have money money that is a
huge one it sounds shallow and vapid but
like I like to go and I think I work
very hard that's right so if I have like
ten days free I want to go somewhere and
it'd be nice if you could go with me
yeah
and I think especially since you're
successful are just having someone at an
equal level because if you start paying
for them in my experience it starts to
become like a maternal vibe yeah and
it's not me dadima home I have
financially responsible I wasn't brave
enough to put has money yeah cuz I
didn't you know I wrote and financially
responsible I
wrote homebody like me I was trying to
get very specific I mean they have any
other ones um let's see it must must
must somewhere I wrote funny to me funny
to you to be funny to everybody I love
that that's a great one like you want to
be the life of a party but like you have
to be able to make me laugh because I
think life of the party I learned is
kind of a red flag charm yes
needing too much attention yes you're
Ted Bundy that's what his fucking murder
may and then doesn't take himself too
seriously yes I wrote good taste in
clothes
yeah I will honestly I'm literally
wearing leopard print Crocs so for me to
say you have to look good is me being
just like like but like dressed fun I
like someone who dresses maybe you were
mismatched pattern and you are wearing
fun Crocs to my Crocs Larry's like good
pussy like I seriously at all I like to
giggle I wrote has a passport yeah even
how to be that specific is to you I
don't need to go to Italian villas with
your probably dude the fact that you
have yes that you were proactive enough
to have it and it's valid
you have your shit together because when
I didn't have a passport my shit was not
together
correct I lost my passport because I was
holding a purse that was too heavy when
I was drunk so I put it down on my
staircase in the hallway of my apartment
building and went to my apartment and I
was like that's the thing that was gonna
make it lighter thing the passport no no
I left the whole bag the whole bag was
too heavy and my passport was in it and
I was like I'll get it in the morning
and then of course in the morning it was
gone so I didn't have a passport for a
long time and I kept I myself who wants
to travel I'm falling more in love with
you every second hold on
just joke oh no oh no that's cuz you're
drinking healthy green I know no this is
a green juice that um oh my god what's
it I don't think I stirred it well
enough a lot of Glazer name-drop turned
me on to
it's called active greens and I eat like
trash so I try to drink this at night
and supposed to have a lot of vitamins
in it and my body's totally rejecting it
yeah your body doesn't want it are you
dying are you okay uh please don't pass
away today I always cry around this time
at night okay now I want to do your
would be nice is it would be nice like
not necessary but would be nice a big
old dick oh le not o LD oh well yeah Big
O le dangle dick a hunger for pussy I
put goes to sleep the same time as me Oh
cuz I die we have such weird schedules
and I'm simply an eternal and some if a
guy goes to bed at 10:00 and I go to bed
at 2:00 and then he waited six and I
wake up it's like yeah I think I'd be
okay with that because I'm a pretty dead
sleeper I don't know live your life do
this really do you like hang out with me
sometimes at night you know that's I
have um reads books it's a dark time my
bar was very mean the things I was asked
outdoorsy oh not close-minded okay
good relationship with family yes I
think because I've had it that's good
for me too because I don't I love my
family
but like my family true I'm not
successful to them and like my cousin
came to one of my shows and she said the
audience seems to really like you and I
was like you don't like me and that was
a way that use in it and again I don't
have to be for everybody I don't give a
shit why don't we do some red flags okay
red red flags are important I talk about
this a lot because I think not enough of
us heed red flags when we see them we
paid him a different color you go out
too often go out too often like somebody
needs to be out every night get the
blurb you have you go to clubs okay
now too often that is a pretty big red
flag if you constantly talk about other
women
as in exes are just women in general
both like women in general exes I I
assume already that you have had someone
before me you'll have someone after me I
don't Road need evidence need to hear
about them that's up especially if it's
pejorative I think guys sometimes think
that we want to hear them just call
their exercise goes or bitches now it's
right but never one time in my life if I
you wanted to think about you fucking
somebody else right yeah some good
another red flag how do you feel about
guys that were makeup I don't mind it I
actually bring it on men should try
harder to look better because men walk
around looking like nasty little
dumpsters and to quote clueless we're
expected to swoon like no look better
yeah look better we were just talking
about this the other day because I've
noticed a couple of my guy friends
wearing makeup but not applied well
because they haven't been trained or
studied this and they just look like
they have fucking cock and grout on
their flick white out on their family
lien you got a blended notice the four
up there is no like my roommate John
Milhiser he gets very upset on podcasts
where I don't say his full name so I
live with a man named John Milhiser John
Milhiser and I went to Sephora and he
was very much like fine this this this
this because he was getting stuff for
auditions yeah and I was like John let
the lady show you how to apply it
yeah get the correct brushes there
doesn't look super cake he's you can see
you guys maybe can't see better the
trained eye knows when something's not
but he's also the first time you put on
makeup you're a baby like I wasn't good
at putting on makeup in the beginning
and then I learned yeah it has to be
within the vicinity of your skin tone
might be a hate crime yeah them together
yes because I think don't go out in
blackface please there's a red flag
blackface is a big past current get all
of it any blackface or brown face but
why did Justin Trudeau's go from being
blackface to brown face in the news
because I believe it was an Arabian
Nights themed party ah but that was
Shoop oh oh whether it was pretty black
to me I don't remember
I just remembered being blackface and
then the news
Brown face nose I think this one was
black face and one was brown face cuz I
think there is multiple why he doesn't
have to pick I like that he's
commitment-phobic about it was like I'll
do all of the ethnicities it was all so
wild how well it was applied it was like
rel to it you're gonna be racist you
really hit it out of the park
you gotta commit I'm like he's done this
many times obably not had photos it's so
interesting to me that people still do
blackface even in like the last ten
years like you know you just don't know
how offensive that is you don't know
that in like so many times to change
your mind yes there's so many times you
can change your mind still doing it
still doing it no weirdo many times you
go yes bad dark well that is a red flag
uh-huh I put ostentatious that's where
it's good tells me to relax or calm down
I see I could use someone to do that I
wrote in a band that is a red flag
unless it's like a band that's doing
well or they're like I play in a band
and this is purely a hobby and I like
doing this yeah for me yeah as opposed
to like one day me and the boys are
gonna make it to Vegas I don't know I
don't know where bands aspire to go I
think I said that because I feel like
I'm a little bit too hard on people in
bands but I think it's because there's a
lot of travel involved and I travel a
lot and yeah truly looking for a
stationary basically I want a actual
basket case with no arms and legs but
who is still actually alive hmm see wait
were they just carrying around baskets
of men in the I guess they were oh I
need to go into my comments and all the
people that attacked me about it because
it was merrily a big thing excuse me can
you please specify how these people are
traveling they're being carried in
baskets I think a handle I do like the
idea though as I think it's like is it
etiology or etymology like the origin of
a word technology that it turned into
basket case meant crazy cuz the basket
cases were acting crazy uncalled for
I mean if I didn't have arm
and legs and someone said we're gonna
put you in the basket and that's how
you're gonna travel I would feel like
really bossy maybe like I can't even
have a wheelchair
come on can you not even just like
swaddle me or put me in a backpack or
something
I put put me in a backpack like that
Yoda backpack that they have at
Disneyland we'll probably get mad at me
about that this is one that I actually
think is pretty good same-day plans is
that a red flag or is that spontaneous
and fun I think that spontaneous and fun
cuz I do things like that I think if I
date a bunch of people who like I was
like their third person they'd add or
like if someone canceled know if I'm
dating so and you're the first person
that I'm coming to with a loony-tune
idea right I like that this is good out
too often talks about other women
blackface you know yourself very well
and it's therapy you don't see that a
lot it's it is such fucking refreshing
breath of fresh air that's those are two
things that should go together and since
you're so clear in this area the last
thing I want to ask you about is are
your friendships because you have such
incredible friendships and I think a lot
of people I know are I wouldn't say
stuck in some unhealthy relationships
but I do think that that's the one area
we kind of don't think about we're like
well this friend causes me stress and
then makes me feel bad but like you know
like break up with friends you just my
therapist once when I was having issues
with a friend she said what are her
redeemable qualities and I took too long
and she went well there you go he that
took too long you should be able to just
list the qualities you like of a friend
and then I said well we have a lot of
history and then my therapist said just
because you have history doesn't mean
you have to stay with somebody this is
friendships relationships everything and
it's okay to move on from a friend so
the people who treat me nice were kind
to me who loved me who make me feel good
those are the people I am friends with
and have you ever had to like I've
broken up with friends and did you do it
or did you just fade away well I
explained there's one specific friend
that I just explained I was like I can't
continue being friends because it has
not been
for me in the last couple of years how'd
that go and it went okay there's still
like sometimes a little reaching out
back and forth but like on my end I was
like for me I don't wish to be rejected
by you anymore oh and I don't wish to
may make I don't wish for our friendship
to be so far on the back burner that I
feel like you never think of me anymore
so I was like I'm done I'm done reaching
out and it it did you felt like you were
chasing the person or you went to
initiate and make plans yeah yeah or I
would say things about like their
significant other who wasn't great and
ended up not being great and then that's
the hardest yeah and then I learned
oh you can't really tell anybody about
their significant uh nope at all ever
that is I where were you 15 years ago
where I did this all day long
uh-huh I was the person that was like I
heard that he's yeah it you can't do it
oh no you should have he's cheating and
you know it you should not agree with it
shut your whore mouth yeah yep that's it
because also someone who's it's just
gonna drive a wedge between you and when
you're in a relationship you can't see
it want it so badly and say you're just
not going to see it no one has ever been
in a relationship they were happy about
it had some ago hey I heard this thing
and they were like oh thank you I guess
I'm done yeah no it has the bridesmaid
that everyone talks about
they're like she talks so much shit
about him I can't believe she showed up
and you're like I don't want to be that
person and you're also meddling in their
journey yes give them the dignity of
your own experience
let let it play out so they can learn
something you're robbing them of a
lesson and I mean I've had I've had very
kind friends I dated somebody on and off
for years who was terrible who
constantly hurt my feelings and I would
tell them stories and they'd be like
well you know what I'm gonna say might
say yes and then we wouldn't move on and
they wouldn't say it now say you it you
know what I'm gonna say I dunno thank
you for listening to me thank you for
not actually saying what you want to say
and we can move on
it's just radical acceptance of where
you are in that space yes and like most
of my friends were very good about that
yeah I mean after like a year of it
you're like well it's hard to watch
someone hurt themselves
yes it's written you love someone it's
the hardest things in the world to disco
I have to radically accept this person's
choices and let them go through whatever
they need to go through you know but I
have had to drop out to the friends
where I go like I just don't think I can
hear about it anymore
it's it's I wanna be able to be in
service and I want to be able to love
you but I the last thing you need right
now yes
is to have a friend who's resentful of
you you know so I just need to draw a
boundary and there I've been friends
where I was like okay I don't talk to
you about this but anymore yeah I guess
so I get the feeling yeah last thing I'm
gonna ask is any great advice you've
gotten that you think people deserve to
know because this podcast idea is it's
good for you and we're trying to pass on
things that are good for you advise you
which you had heard earlier um - for
women to ask men how much they made
doing the same thing you're doing Wow
and even if you're making the same
amount ask for more Wow is usually
people have more money Wow you opening
offers are just that they're opening
offers and the worst thing someone can
say to you is no I'm not gonna give that
to you but the best thing that can
happen is you ask for more money you
raise your quote the next job you have
that's your quote that's right so if
you're not gonna pay me what I was paid
in my last job then I guess I'm not
taking this job and it's okay to say no
and it's okay to seem like you're a
bitch because you know what you want
because you're not a bit you just know
what you want that's correct
yeah it was a long time like I had a
manager once so there was an email so I
had a show on MTV called loosely exactly
Nicole and they were like let's I want
you to we want you to live tweet it and
I was like well if I live tweet I'm
tweeting it to like people who follow me
that's like asking someone who's in my
house to come to my room how do we get
people come into the house yeah yeah and
they were like oh oh and then like we
had like a pretty good discussion about
it and then after we got off the phone
my manager called me back and was like I
think you should apologize you really
seemed you know and I was like what he
was like you know and I was like a bitch
she's like well you said it and I was
like no you implied it
I'll apologize for you know trying like
I was like I'll apologize if you think
that's what I should do but I truly
phrase it in a way where I was like I'm
not sorry I'm not sorry for wanting to
promote my show as hard and as I can I'm
proud
it I'm not sorry for speaking my mind
what am I supposed to just go oh okay
mm-hmm I think that's not how you
navigate a career that's how you
navigate life by just being meek meek
and a bystander in your own life it
serves no one no it serves no one and
again the worst thing they could say is
no yeah and also yeah that's been so
hard for me for so long cuz I'm like I
don't want to ruffle any feathers
because I'm already lucky to be here
it's like no not no I'm not like there's
a reason why you're there like I was on
a shoot today won't say what things we
started early and then at like 1:00
lunch hadn't happened and I was like
where's lunch yes I was like you can't
call us this early oh then not feed us
no I mean like it's outside and I was
like so it's ready and nobody said
anything that is disrespectful that's
right and then one of the other people
was like eating really quick before we
started to shoot again yeah I was like
no I'm not saying a word until you
finish your food this is stupid that you
have to rush to eat your food to get
what you get out of here 20 minutes
earlier and to me I'm fucking the
bitchiest thing I can do is not stand up
for myself because then I'm gonna get
worse work yes and then what this isn't
gonna go to series outlaw or be Gilead
and then you'll be upset in the Edit and
that's right I'd rather be a bitch now
so that you like me later instead of you
like me now yeah product be bad later
and then sometimes people think I'm a
little too Curt because I'll tell a
director give me a line right yeah we
can do 90 I thought it was good yeah if
you didn't think it was good then you
tell me exactly how you want me to not
do it yeah I don't care
I already did what I thought it was good
just take it for you yeah and then some
directors like no no I don't want you to
make me acting like I can't handle bully
Ken I'm fine I noticed this a little bit
in the last couple like years with you
know all the good things me too is done
but now everyone's treating me like I am
like made of last I'm sorry okay I'm
like I'm on I'm okay I'm fine
there was AI had to do a sex scene never
was like you don't have to I'm like it's
written it's in there literally we have
to do and they're like it only if you're
comfortable like okay now you're just
insane now you're treating me like I'm
gonna sue everyone and I'm
rational monster there's legal liability
over correction it's like just don't be
I learned some me to stuff so I thought
it was funnier in my early twenties I
think I got my shows 25 or 26 or
something
maybe old enough to know better but at
like Mondays I got how's everyone's
wicked did we all fuck then my friend
was like Nicole that would like it would
be like if you walked into your job at a
bank and your boss went house every
weekend it all fuck count the money I
was like oh but she was like that's
she's like so maybe you might want to
stop doing this stick her fingers but
like hands we'd all just run around and
finger but each other I'm gonna do that
now no no finger butter
no there was finger butting there was
swiping people's buns like a credit card
like there was I mean there with
everyone's uh we used to photoshop
people's heads on making bodies and put
them all over the wall I mean we did was
wild I never I now have to say to
contestants I'm a comic
sometimes I work blue that's just how my
mind works and then I work backwards to
get something clean yeah and it's been
exhausting because people watch the show
with their kids or whatever and then
they get to the set and then I'm like oh
that cake looks like I don't know and
then it's like someone's grandmother
who's like no so now it's like just born
it was weird because the first two
seasons nobody had seen it yet right so
I and then also they didn't know what
the show was gonna be so I was just
doing whatever but now that it's like a
thing and kids like it it's been it's
been very jarring people love that show
they really do does that feel good it
does feel good it feels good that uh
cause a lot of the moments that they
really like have been improvised so like
it's just fun the people like my weirds
I have a weird sense of humor how does
that mean
so cool you've been reworked amazing I'm
to be nominated for something no but
like going is so wild you're so close to
the most famous people and you can touch
them if you want and make it seem like
it were you scared at all or nervous at
the Emmy no because I mean we were gonna
lose I just was right of speech no we
were definitely gonna lose why because
we were against RuPaul's Drag Race oh
I'm not a producer so I wouldn't have
gotten an Emmy oh no I don't I think I
would have just gone up there and like
stayed in the back Oh got it
thank you I love you are you gonna do
after this I just want to know the next
hour of your life okay I'm gonna drive
home that should take about 25 minutes
huh and then I'm gonna pack cuz I gotta
go to Philadelphia tomorrow Oh Elite
Delphia are you playing this won't be
out then but let's uh we're uh parks
casino and a casino before it's so fun
and weird I'm really it's gonna be so
it's so many people that have just lost
a bunch of money and they need to laugh
so bad but they're also kind of
miserable and has like they just
screamed my resume at me like I want
that I don't want to tell a joke just
yell at me and what are we where else
can everybody find you on Instagram at
Nicole Byer Intuit are coming out no way
I have a book coming out May 19 you
wrote another book I know the first book
yeah it's called hash tag very fat hash
tag very brave the fat girls guide to
being brave and not a melancholy
dejected weeping fat girl in a bikini
down in the dumps it's really lucky to
what don't you also have a picture okay
so we have some pictures okay the
self-help book let's see if I can get it
right
hashtag very fat hashtag very brave the
fat girls guide to being brave and not a
melancholy dejected down in the dumps
weeping fat girl in a bikini I got it
it's a lot and when it took about May
19th 2020 yeast you're gonna do a big
book tour on the whole jail I don't know
maybe should when does this come out
this comes out in like two weeks I'll be
in Portland Oh fun and then I'll be in
San Jose so just like good um oh good I
love San Jose
yeah you think I've only been once oh
that's where my favorite venue man
almost hit me with a car last time I was
in San Jose I'm sorry and then he
stopped just short of me and leaned out
and said almost nailed it you sure he
wasn't flirting no he was trying to make
a joke by almost killing me because he
leaned out of his car and said almost
nailed it San Jose you just lost me
yawns I'm not offending your sit it was
bad don't do that don't do that don't
kill me I'm so hot I'm so warm too deep
here in this room I didn't want to fuck
up the audio I'm sweaty and I have to
pee pee yeah I have to pee
[Music]